here we go right let's get serious again
the brave men and women of our military
worked long hours in horrendous
conditions so that we can all sleep easy
at night yeah when they leave the
service behind they often denied the
help and respect they deserve
a recent survey conducted by Saffir a
leading military charity has found that
some veterans feel there's a disconnect
between themselves and civvy Street in
things like employment and have
suggested this is discriminatory towards
him seventy percent of veterans surveyed
said employees did not properly value
their skills or abilities questions such
as through your PTSD or how many people
have you killed and not relevant we're
looking for a job veterans don't want
preferential treatment or even worse
pity but they do want to be treated
equally if you were in the frontline
defending this country you should be in
the front of the queue for help when you
need looking after
and discriminating against these brave
vets is bang out of order so how many
people have you killed
I think you're right I mean I think most
in most countries you would expect
people who've served in the front line
for their country who are here to be
given every thing every assistance and a
leg up when they when they come home and
join civvy Street but it's not working
because a lot of these guys and I've got
some I've got a bit of a chart don't
know we do charts but let's just look at
some of these figures yeah seventy-five
percent felt that they were not as
respected as your emergency services
she's what I felt right and sixty-seven
percent felt there was less respect when
armed forces were not in conflict all
right okay and the last one I'm going to
give you 62 percent felt undervalued by
society and that was all source by so
far and they've got an old dream of
other facts and figures that's on there
but basically private bacon that gets
out nowadays and he doesn't feel valued
by society and to in some cases will
deny his service yeah so he doesn't have
to put on his CV and he doesn't have to
tell people what you did because he's
afraid that they'll just donate and the
borscht and every in those statistics
the word that jumps out at me is
they for what they feel when they can't
leave the frontline and come back is a
loss of maybe self-esteem and they don't
feel that they're being validated
they're not validated doing the day jobs
in civilian society but if you actually
look at the evidence of surveys there is
no discrimination in veterans compared
to non veterans I've gotten jobs when I
came out I couldn't get accounts with
that woman right right and I needed
accounts now and I was categorically
told you know are so far back in this
queue we're gonna have to come down and
pay nothing alright so because actually
because I'd voluntarily release myself
from the Army and they said you know
anything well I don't want to be the
Army anyway you know how maybe not the
back of the queue you know at the time
you know I'd come back from Sierra Leone
where I had fought frontline you know
and that sort of thing so you know I
felt discriminated against for my
service he said thanks again well I
believe I should have been we can't find
definitive proof it's always going to be
how someone no I mean in the statistics
the rate of the the percentage of vets
just get me that we need to say what the
Ministry of Defence and as you listen to
this you served and I want you to listen
to every single word fill and tell me
whether you think it's true the minister
defense say the following veterans make
a fantastic contribution to society the
vast majority go on to live happy
healthy and successful lives it's right
that we support people when they leave
service that's why we have a range of
initiatives in place to make sure people
transition successfully including
training education and financial support
our flagship Career Transition
partnership provides one-to-one guidance
to individuals leaving the military as
well as training and employment
opportunities
any of that time that you I get that no
no I actually agree with someone up
there said okay the fact that there are
people now there are very very many
successful veterans out there okay and I
get you know get decent jobs and down
but the fact that there are some
struggling the fact that it is too many
for me and the fact that it's been
identified we've been with in Safa and
other organizations that the
resettlement in to civilian life
yeah isn't what it could know and I
don't think you're gonna get an oven in
June stamina but I just want to read
this I think important everybody knows
this there's something called the Armed
Forces covenant which you will know
which yeah I don't blame you I don't
blame you for laughing it's meant to be
it was actually put in law in 2011 it's
meant that we show armed forces and
families deserve our respect and support
and fair treatment it is a low yeah all
I want to say is our veterans have a lot
of transferable skills but we don't do a
good enough job of actually transferring
those skills to jobs this is a true
story right okay very quickly when our
money I realized I left after I left
after 15 years okay so I got out and I
had to do nothing about CV Street so I
said right I'll go down to job center
and I'll get yourself one of these
crisis lines because I'll see everybody
else a signal line the lady walking
around 300 got money and I'm not
I love the butcher's at that so I went
down there filled mr. Thomas woman was
very nice yeah it turns out that none of
my skills in the Army correlate it'll
transfer to anything the city street
will have happened yeah I'm an
underwater knife fighter on my rounds
with bringer of death because the
qualifications were on paper so it's for
the only qualification I had okay was
from school and it was a story so she
put all this in the computer okay all
this in computer and basically all I had
was more qualifications with 15 years
your service table the only job and I
had to go apply for this job or I didn't
get me I think that'd be 76 quid or
whatever it was that's gonna apply for
this job right so could you lollipop man
so from from cyber squadron steely-eyed
bring on an international scale to
lollipop man
luckily set to go down and that morning
I got a letter from a friend of one
saying could I do some stuff from
somewhere else I just finished breaking
I finished just yesterday actually an
employment Roadshow we go up and down
the countries on it for years and we
always get always get X militia people
coming and talking to us and there is a
definite gap with how people are being
supported in
presenting themselves from military life
into like what we call civic Street in
terms of their skill sets and I think
that we really fail so first of all on
the broader point I think we fail
veterans massively and it makes me feel
I feel so you think that you need to do
and sometimes so when I look at the
Seavey's of like some of these vets
they've got fantastic CVS but they
haven't for example I don't know when
you're in the Army you've got a lot of
management skills you've got
coordination organization timekeeping
planning strategy you got all of these
things at arm under pressure yeah and
sometimes what you need is someone that
understands business has to actually be
mentoring those people and helping them
present themselves in a way that's right
for business and I think we do feel on
that but there are some great employers
that work and they focus on vets and I
really respect those guys business
understand how bad reality that this is
one of the solutions that we need to
come to that the businesses need to be
made aware but you need something you
need a middle person cuz what you need
is someone that understands business to
work with the vets and sit there like
what I've just been doing for the last
few days and sit there and go right ok
listen to me what this because I don't
know what are so overall it is the list
to me what you used to do within that
role right okay you've got team team
skills you've got playing this that so
then it's pulling out those skills and
presenting it in a way that a business
would understand that because it
translates to a business language and
that is what can be done you can't
Jaguar Land Rover the service leavers
employed since we signed Jaguar Land
Rover signed the Armed Forces covenant
in 24 862 men and women they've taken on
in four years so it can be done if a
firm wants to in the comments both
probably very Huntley let's hear from
one of them Conservative MP Leo Doherty
it's an important part of the duty of
care that the government has to look
after people who deploy to conflict
zones and fight on our behalf
what they've done their duty and we must
do ours by them I mean the truth is is
that if I know someone's been in the
Armed Forces I think that's a feather in
your cap and I look like I definitely
give them a second look me to get my
meaning
I hear ya Oh repeatedly hear stories
where it's not that case you know really
I think the plan says well you know
there was in the resettlement dominantly
it's a guy the guy in charge was someone
would be a guy that's been in the Army
for 30 years we need to bring someone
who's experienced the system can't you
do some forward thinking and actually
you whoever's in charge of like
education etc within the army can't you
actually sit and develop qualifications
in the first instance that does
correlate to the worlds beyond because
if you're actually taking people into
the army and you're actually doing
something which is recognized so when
you're training you are getting an
output of recognizable skills that would
make the transition easier as well we
are going to the breaks oh I'm sorry
asking the break you're watching the
pledge on Sky News up next why
fast-fashion is no longer my style
[Music]